下面我为大家演示一下如何复制商品,首先点击左边菜单的授权复制,进来后点击设置模板,点击添加模板,模板名称可以自定义,方便您管理和识别。
下方的内容根据需求设置,后续复制的商品会按照这个模板设置的规则来进行。
价格这里,根据实际情况,可以设置階梯价格,也可以设置单一价格。
设置以后点击加号,价格就设置好了。
页面的最下方,有一个商品过滤默认是勾选的。
如果您不需要过滤取消勾选,点击确定就可以了。
接下来点击选择商品复制。
先选择分组和源店铺,源店铺就是有商品的店铺。
如果不是全店复制,还可以根据条件进行筛选。
还可以点击复制标记,选择未复制的商品。
点击查询。
选择商品。
商品支持翻页选择。
选好后,点击立即复制,会出现您选中的商品。
这里您可以核对一下,显示的数量和您选中的商品是否一致。
一致的话,点击。
会弹出下一步。
这个页面会出现您这里添加的所有店铺。
您要复制到哪个店铺,就在哪个店铺这里选择复制模板。
这里请注意,因为源店铺也会显示在这里。
所以,如果源店铺不需要复制的话,就不用勾选。
点击确定。
复制任务就创建好了。
这个页面还有一个修改复制标记的功能。
比如您店铺有些商品不需要复制,可以选择这些商品。
标记为您复制。
这样您在会复制的这个进行筛选。标记为以复制的商品就不会显示了。
最后点击查看复制记录,可以查看您提交的任务。
点击详细,可以查看实际的复制进度和详情。
可以根据复制的状态进行筛选。
如果发现有复制失败的商品,可以根据失败提示的内容进行修改,然后重新复制。
謝謝